.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
JOE DISAPPEARS FOR DAYS LIKE HE
IS CAMPAIGNING.
HIDES UNDER MORE LIDS THAN OSCAR
THE GROUCH.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T EXPECT
A SUCCESSFUL EVACUATION WITHOUT
THE THREAT OF STRINGS.
-- DESTRUCTION IF YOU STOP IT.
IF THE REAL PROBLEMS ARE WHITE
RACISM, HOW CAN WE TELL THE
TALIBAN WHAT TO DO?
WE LOST OUR MORAL AUTHORITY TO
A GROUP WHO HAS THE TERM
OPPRESSOR IN THEIR JOB
DESCRIPTION.
IF ONLY THEY HAD TRUMP 2024
TOWELS.
JOE BIDEN BECAME A LAME DUCK
PRESIDENCY IN RECORD TIME.
MY APOLOGY TO DUCKS EVERYWHERE.
FOR THE GREAT UNIFIER HE HAS AN
UNBELIEVABLE TALENT OF BREAKING
THINGS INTO PIECES.
HE SHOULD NOT BE RUNNING
A COUNTRY.
HE SHOULD DEMOLISH KITCHENS ON
THIS OLD HOUSE.
WE SEE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
TATTERS AS CRIME WAGES AND WATCH
OUR ENERGY POLICIES IMPLODE AS
GAS PRICES SOAR.
BUT HE HELPED RUSSIA AND OPEC.
NO WONDER THE MEDIA AND ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS WORKED TO GET THIS
GUY ELECTED.
THEY ARE QUIET NOW.
THEY BURIED THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP.
IT'S HARDER TO FIND THAN A DOM
LEMON VIEWER.
THE PRESIDENCY IS GRAY AND
ROTTEN ON THE INSIDE.
WHAT IS NEXT.
JOE KENNEDY SUMS IT UP.
>> THE BIGGEST TERRORISTS
VICTORY SINCE 9-11.
JIHADISTS WHO WANT TO HURT THIS
COUNTRY ARE REINVIGORATED TODAY.
>> Greg: TELL THAT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY WILL SAY IT'S DOMESTIC
TERRORISM WE NEED TWO WORRY
ABOUT.
IT'S THE RED SOX.
-- THE INSURRECTION.
THOSE WERE THE DAYS WHEN YOU
COULD PRETEND YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS WERE EVIL WHEN IT
REALITY IT WAS YOUR IMCOMPETENCE
ALL ALONG.
LET'S WELCOME TODAY'S GUESTS.
DAVID McDOWELL.
>> [APPLAUDING].
>> Greg: FORMER ACTING U.S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SHE IS LIKE A SMOKE ALARM.
LOUD PIERCING AND YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE THE BATTERY.
KAT TIMPF.
AND A GRAIN SILO IS HIS COFFEE
THERMOS.
MY MASTER SIDE KICK TIRES!
-- TYRUS!
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE JUST DID "THE FIVE."
>> TITILLATING.
>> Greg: WATCH YOUR MOUTH.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF JOE'S
SPEECH TODAY?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
TALIBAN BEING ON TWITTER?
>> THE SPEECH WAS A ZERO.
THAT'S HOW MANY TIMES WE
ADDRESSED WHAT WAS GOING ON IN
AFGHANISTAN.
THE TALIBAN ON TWITTER AND TRUMP
IS NOT.
THAT WILL GET RESOLVED.
THE TALIBAN PLACE BY THE RULES,
THE RULES SET BY THE LEFT.
THAT'S THEIR FIXATION.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT ENERGY
POLICY.
I HOPE THAT THE DEBACLE